مسار تطبيع العلاقات التركيه السوريه في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو انطلق والملفات
الساخنه بين الطرفين وضعت على الطاوله
لاول مره منذ 12 عاما موسكو راعيه
المصالحه والعرابه لهذه المصالحه طالبت
بخريطه الطريق لدفع مسار التقارب بين كل
من دمشق وانقره لضمان المتطلبات الامنيه
للاطراف كافه ولكن قبل اجتماع موسكو كشفت
وزاره الدفاع التركيه عن وجود مخطط لانشاء
مركز تنسيق ميداني مع النظام السوري هذا
المركز هو الاستمرار الخطه الخط الساخن
بين كل من روسيا ايران وتركيا واليوم
سيصبح مركزا للتنسيق الميداني ولكن بعدما
اصبح النظام السوري جزءا منه وفقا طبعا
مصادر سوريه اما ابرز اهداف مركز التنسيق
الميداني في سوريا فهو فهي طبعا تعزيز
الثقه المتبادله وتنسيق الميداني للانشطه
الموجوده في المنطقه كما قالت انقره هنا
فيما اكد الخبراء بانها محاوله تركيا
لضمان وقف اطلاق النار في ادلب واستجابه
النظام لجهود التركيه في مكافحه الارهاب
وضمان استقرار المنطقه امنيا وعسكريا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات